major cities rocked by massive bloodshed
this fourth of july weekend
nearly 260 people reportedly shot and
killed
across the country and almost 700 people
were wounded in total
the epicenter of this out of control
violence chicago
the windy city saw its most violent
weekend of the year at least a hundred
people were shot
including children and 18 people were
killed
other crime way up to like in san
francisco where a group of thieves they
looted a high-end department store and
no one even tried to stop him
the city being rocked by a shoplifting
epidemic right now
all right greg the only thing that's
really going to stop the bleeding is you
just have to arrest
prosecute and then incarcerate the
shooters
i just don't understand why the local
authorities just don't do that it's that
simple
i i honestly believe that this is a
political
strategy because the media and the
democrats
are in power together they got the guy
in the white house they're in control
so anytime you acknowledge crime it kind
of puts it on them
so they don't want they don't want it so
they're choosing politics over people
they're okay with all the shootings and
stuff rather than accepting
responsibility and fixing it so we have
to trick them into caring
how do we do that we have to say that
we're on their side
we're gonna we should say you know what
i'm totally for the shootings
i'm told you know what i am so demon
marcus don't stop there
what i'm saying is like they don't care
about this stuff
because we care we this is a political
choice on that part
this is a team sport decision on the
democrats and the media to let joy reid
copied the don lemon school of
journalism and said that there's no
spike in violence because she doesn't
know any friends
that were that of exp it's like oh it's
not raining so there must not
ever be rain and it it is she's dumb
enough now she could be
on cnn prime time but uh so i think the
only way to do it is
we have to be we have to we have to take
their
stance and force them to take hours
that's the only way
geraldo 180 100 people as we said shot
in chicago over the weekend
it said nearly all cases no suspects
were taken into custody
what does that tell you well it tells
you that the there's no cooperation with
the system with the authorities but
i think this is very very deep what's
happening here this is
a crime wave that is affecting the
black people in america in a way that is
so profoundly destructive
it is the number one cause of death
homicide is the number one cause of
death
for black men up to the age of 44
homicide is the number one cause of
death we got to absorb that
i really believe that they don't mention
it because it is too difficult
they have no no way no ideas to
fix it without stop and frisk and
roadblocks and you know traffic stops
and and so forth i really do
think that this is a crisis that will
mark
this era in our lives this is the civil
rights
issue of our time uh the death of uh you
know within the black community
all of those murders you talk about
chicago you don't you don't say the next
way
they were every one of them was black
the shooter and the victim were all
black i mean
at what point does president biden
and all the democrats and everyone else
and god
they've got to recognize that this is a
crisis and it's not going to fix it
and katie the people in these
neighborhoods especially in chicago
practically begging
the authorities to help them to send
help to
to bring more police in to solve these
murders
and they're just getting ignored yeah
well because a lot of the media and the
left have completely racialized
everything so now they've equated good
policing
with racism and therefore everybody's
kind of throwing up their hands and
going
yeah there's a crime wave but you know i
don't want to get in the middle of being
politically incorrect or
feel like i'm going to get called racist
for doing my job and therefore
things spin completely out of control in
the very communities that geraldo's
talking about
but this is a la this is a direct result
of a lack of deterrence there's
no incentive not to be a criminal right
now and then there's no consequences for
people's actions and that combination
is a recipe for disaster i mean i went
into a walgreens in new york city last
week
and was watching these guys just carry
stuff out of the store
just leaving with stuff out of the store
and i was looking at the cashiers who
are not white by the way
here they are working an honest job
they're trying to make a living
the manager's just beside himself people
just walking outside the door
and where's the justice for those people
who are there doing the right thing
working a real job and they're
completely victimized by this entire
system and the politicians
who want more money for crime bailouts
and who refuse to
address the problem well joy reid didn't
see that heist
i did so it didn't happen it didn't
happen the other thing is
that you talked about the things that
need to happen but the deterrence issue
is a really big one
today governor cuomo announced some big
like executive order because he's going
to go after guns
gun crime okay well this is actually
what the anti-crime task force used to
do
and if you look at the i mean any like a
five-year-old could figure out the cause
and effect here it's not that hard
but one thing that's really strange and
greg hit on it is that the white house
looks at their polling
believing they look at it every day and
the two issues that are pulling them
down the most are crime
and immigration on on those two issues
and i mean i'm talking they're like at
31
approval for uh the immigration piece
and crime is way down as well so
the fact that they sit back and do
nothing
one it's morally abhorrent but two it
doesn't even make any political sense
did they pull traffic in that at all
because i would bet that that was the
number one issue facing americans in
this country
over crime perhaps traffic traffic
trust me it's not killing people but
killing us in another hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else